[Música]
i
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de france 24 en español sobre
la actualidad europea yo soy esther
herrera caro desde el parlamento europeo
en bruselas es un placer saludarles en
el programa de hoy analizamos el papel
de china en el mundo y sus relaciones
con la unión europea a que se enfrenta
el bloque europeo y cómo afecta sus
relaciones con américa latina' antes de
pasar al debate hacemos un repaso sobre
el desafío que puede suponer china y por
qué preocupa a la unión europea y al
mundo
china es un complicado socio para la
unión europea hace dos años el bloque
europeo sitúa al gigante asiático como
un rival sistémico aunque al mismo
tiempo cerró un acuerdo de inversiones a
finales de 2020 el parlamento europeo ya
dijo que no ratificará la unión europea
aprobó sanciones recientemente contra
altos cargos de la región de xinjiang
por el trato degradante y la vulneración
de derechos humanos contra la minoría
uigur una población musulmana que según
organizaciones independientes sufre una
persecución en la nación asiática
estas sanciones provocaron tensiones
entre bruselas y beijing algo que no
ocurría desde las manifestaciones de la
plaza de tianmen en
1989 los países europeos no dejan de
preocuparse por los aliados que continúa
ganando china a nivel mundial la más
reciente con los talibanes que dirigen
ahora afganistán lo menos importante
también influencia que mantiene en el
este de europa y con varios países de
américa latina' la pandemia del
coronavirus también puso en alerta la
unión europea tras develar que existe
una enorme dependencia no sólo en
material médico sino en tecnología por
esta razón bruselas también trata de
revertir situación apostando más por una
producción europea
y para analizar estas complicadas
relaciones con china contamos con los
eurodiputados javi lópez del grupo
socialdemócrata y con jordi cañas del
grupo renovar europa javi y jordi
bienvenidos a europa hoy empezamos
contigo jordi me gustaría preguntarte
primero de todo la unión europea se ha
despertado demasiado tarde con china y
se ha dado cuenta que es un rival
sistémico sobre todo en materia de
comercio
pues yo creo que podríamos responderte
muy sencillo si la europea va tarde la
unión europea no tiene una estrategia
clara ni definida como responder vasca
el desafío al reto que significa una
china cada vez más potente una china
cada vez más presente los mercados una
china que está empezando también a creer
a asumir un rol político
estratégico y de seguridad y ante esta
situación lo repito que no creo que
tengamos que calificar de desafío
todavía sino ese reto la unión europea
no ha estado a la altura y no está
sabiendo articular una respuesta
positiva
digamos ofensiva en el sentido positivo
frente a lo que significaba una china
que controla una parte muy importante de
la producción global que se ha
convertido nos hemos vuelto dependientes
sino dependientes en muchas de nuestras
cadenas de suministro de muchos de
nuestros productos que necesitamos en
nuestro labor como como economía
transformadora y eso supone un reto que
lo que tenemos que hacer es dejar de
pensar que hacen los chinos
tenerlo en cuenta y sobre todo saber que
queremos hacer como europeos cómo
respondemos ante ese crecimiento chino y
esa estrategia china que se ha ido
desarrollando por latina mente en las
últimas décadas y que hay que reconocer
que ha conseguido sus objetivos
javi me gustaría preguntarte en la
rivalidad existente entre eeuu y chino
parece ser que la unión europea se
quiere mantener un poco más al margen es
la estrategia adecuada
también parece adecuado la estrategia
que se ha ido planteando con china
europa somos aliados para los retos
globales al mismo tiempo combatir el
cambio climático regular la
globalización somos competidores
económicos es un auténtico gigante
económico y somos rivales especialmente
por lo que hace al sistema de gobernanza
porque representamos dos polos
diferentes de gobernar a las democracias
en nuestro caso y en su caso estamos
ante una autocracia
y por lo que hace a la relación con eeuu
que habrá entrado en una época de
tensiones yo creo que con eeuu
compartimos un paraguas por lo que hace
nuestra seguridad y nuestra defensa por
lo que hace la otan o un pilar
fundamental y obviamente es un socio
estratégico para defender las
democracias en el mundo
ahora bien debiéramos de ser capaces de
tener nuestras posiciones propias tener
más capacidades en materia de seguridad
y defensa
será un amortiguador durante los
siguientes años en las tensiones que
puedan haber entre china y eeuu creo que
es el papel constructivo que le pertoca
a la unión europea y además creo que
haríamos un buen favor hacia el mundo si
no nos colocamos de lado de una de las
dos grandes grandes potencias y
favorecemos la lógica de la
confrontación ese debiera ser un modo de
ver papel de europa recordando los
brazos tan importantes que tenemos en el
atlántico con eeuu
los dos sois buenos conocedores de
américa latina me gustaría preguntar a
los dos parece ser que la unión europea
a menudo se le critica que no estado
suficientemente presente en el
continente que china ahora está mucho
más presente ha sido china más rápida o
la unión europea no actuado suficiente
bueno lamentablemente tengo que afirmar
con rotundidad que américa latina no es
una prioridad para el conjunto de la
unión europea es una pérdida para
algunos de los países unión europea pero
no para el conjunto de sus instituciones
más allá de la retórica y a los hechos
me remito ahora mismo tenemos
paralizados un gran acuerdo como se
acuerdo con una europea mercosur de un
acuerdo de asociación política comercial
y estratégica que está siendo analizado
por los intereses de algunos de algunos
países
estamos convirtiéndonos en un actor
político y comercial
vamos a decir poco poco simpático es
decir estamos siempre exigiendo
condiciones y nunca proponiendo
condiciones es decir que china no
pregunta nada si en la comercial china
intercambia ichi nada colabora el china
invierte en europea prácticamente lo que
hace siempre es exigir y repito a los
hechos me remito más allá de la retórica
porque si no somos capaces de
identificar la naturaleza del problema
no podemos solventarlo para para alguna
parte de los europeos y una parte
importante de los países europeos entre
ellos españa la unión de américa latina
iberoamérica es una prioridad
estratégica tenemos que conseguir que
esa piedad estratégica sea también una
prioridad para la unión europea y no lo
es eso es un gravísimo error porque
estamos cediendo todo el espacio a china
igual que la naturaleza odia el vacío en
la política internacional en la
geopolítica y la vida comercial la
naturaleza hoy al vacío y cuando alguien
abandona un espacio alguien lo ocupa una
unión europea no está ocupando el
espacio que le corresponde no está
trabajando adecuadamente que una
estrategia muy difusa miren esto de un
ejemplo en la toma de posesión de von
der leyen no cito américa latina
y sus prioridades en la estrategia de
comercio de la unión europea américa
latina no tenía un capítulo específico
por lo tanto lo que tenemos que hacer es
saber ser capaces de convencer al
conjunto de los países de un europeo al
conjunto de las instituciones también a
la comisión de que el refuerzo de las
relaciones con américa latina es clave
que refuerza las relaciones comerciales
pero también de asociación políticas y
de cooperación es clave porque tenemos
retos comunes retos compartidos la
mayoría de los países latinoamericanos
son democracias china no lo es y sin
embargo el finales de diciembre del año
pasado la unión europea encabezada por
merkel matrón firmaron fue afirmaron
acordaron un acuerdo de inversión con
china
sin tener en cuenta que es una dictadura
partido único no sólo una autocracia no
no es una dictadura partido único
que no respeta a muchos de los derechos
humanos que incumplen la mayoría de los
acuerdos de la oit
y eso mismo se lo estamos exigiendo al
mercosur de
democracias países que cumplen la
mayoría de los acuerdos de la oit países
que están comprometidos en el cambio
climático que hacen a los acuerdos de
parís es decir somos fuertes con los
débiles y débil con los fuertes pues eso
tiene que cambiar porque para la unión
europea-américa latina iberoamérica
hispanoamérica tiene que ser una
prioridad geopolítica y económica
además de cultural estratégica en el
futuro
si el inglés que no estoy de acuerdo con
lo que dice jordi tenemos pendiente tres
acuerdos de asociación dos para renovar
chile y méxico- muy relevantes y
mercosur que sería el más importante que
nunca ha firmado la unión europea y eso
está bastante paralizado y durante los
últimos cinco años el diálogo a primer
nivel
llegamos al nivel de primeros ministros
y presidentes ha estado paralizado muy
enredado todas las relaciones por la
grave crisis que vive venezuela mientras
tanto que ha pasado durante los últimos
diez años china ha multiplicado el
comercio con américa latina' por 26 26
ha ido durante los últimos dos años
jinping ocho veces a la región han
habido dos cumbres unión europea celac
dos cumbres china celac cuando estaban
paralizadas con la unión europea y ahora
se prepara la tercera se no sólo hay una
relación comercial muy intensa entre
china y américa latina
no sólo ha pasado china de ser un gran
suministrador de crédito a la región a
ser un gran inversor es que además una
relación política del más alto nivel
cuando nosotros durante los últimos diez
años hemos estado enredados básicamente
en crisis internas y geopolíticamente
muy focalizados con nuestra vecindad
tanto en el norte de áfrica oriente
medio como en el este y como bien
explicaba jordi y américa latina es un
socio estratégico en una zona ahora
mismo un espacio de alta competición
geopolítica entre grandes poderes europa
puede encontrar un socio fiable en
américa latina con valores compartidos
con vínculos históricos culturales y que
además representamos en términos
generales una misma forma de ver el
mundo desde la democracia el
multilateralismo la voluntad de una
gobernanza inclusiva una globalización
con normas una agenda común y
desaprovechamos una oportunidad porque
cuando antes hablaba sobre capacidades
propias y posiciones propias no algo que
lo denominamos la autonomía estratégica
en el mundo también significa alianzas
propias y con américa latina tenemos una
potencia en alianza de primer nivel si
yo creo que estamos corremos el riesgo
la unión europea de el riesgo de una
especie de aislamiento voluntario a
veces detrás de conceptos que son
estratégicas se oculta un proteccionismo
verde en este caso un proteccionismo que
parece lanzar un mensaje de miedo a
competir defensivo y creo que la unión
europea tiene todas las capacidades para
asumir un liderazgo global lo que a mí
me gustaría curva afuera el tercer polo
del nuevo multilateralismo global es
decir estados unidos-china pero también
a una europea podemos y es más debemos
hacerlo porque si no somos capaces de
construir ese tercer polo que sea capaz
de equilibrar de lanzar mensaje y
constructivos positivos de valores de
principios corremos el riesgo de vernos
arrastrados una nueva guerra fría la
cual europa en el medio sin tener una
voz propia y una capacidad de decisión
muy muy brevemente me gustaría preguntar
de cara a la 26 la unión europea quiere
tener a china como aliado pero china
dice que la neutralidad climática al
menos no hasta 2060 se puede contar con
chino también en esta cuestión tenemos
que poder contar con china para esta
cuestión
ellos dicen que quieren llegar a la
neutralidad climática en 2060 nosotros
en 2050 pero también hay que recordar
que hicimos nosotros la revolución
industrial 150 años antes que china es
necesario que china se implique porque
significa más del 25 por ciento de las
emisiones en el mundo nosotros el 8 por
ciento también es verdad que emisiones
por cápita por persona a eeuu hace el
doble que china por ejemplo pero china
es necesario en los espacios
multilaterales es necesario para
combatir el cambio climático es
necesario para comprometerse para los
grandes retos y ahora mismo es un
gigante en términos políticos
diplomáticos y económicos y tenemos que
adaptarnos a eso tomar buena nota y
pensar en nuestros valores en nuestros
intereses por relación con américa
latina y también a los grandes órganos
multilaterales o jingping no participará
tampoco nunca ha participado en una cop
esperemos que sea un éxito de
compromisos multilaterales y que europa
sea capaz también de liderar la gente de
verde en el mundo muchas gracias ya no
tenemos más tiempo muchas gracias jordi
javi nosotros lo dejamos aquí muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros en europa
hoy en france 64 nosotros le esperamos
en el próximo programa de france 24
español muchas gracias por vernos
[Música]